إحدى اللاعبات التي تأمل أن تكون حاضرة في
مشهد Fink Accord في وقت لاحق من هذا العام هي
السلوفينية بيا بابنيت، وقد
تفوقت المراهقة في الجولة
الأوروبية للسيدات منذ أن أصبحت محترفة
قبل عامين، وقد جعل موسمها لعام 2022
عالم الجولف يقف ويلاحظ
أنه كان أفضل موسم.  حتى الآن، في
مسيرتي الاحترافية، بدأت بشكل
جيد حقًا مع المركز الثالث في شيفرون،
وبعد ذلك كان العام بأكمله جيدًا جدًا،
وتحسن أدائي إلى الأفضل، لذا نعم،
أنا سعيد حقًا، فلنتحدث عن لعبة
شيفرون الكلاسيكية، وعن مقدار الثقة
التي منحتك إياها.  في مسيرتك المهنية ككل
وكذلك ثقتك في
الفوز بلقب رئيسي قريبًا، لقد
أظهر لي أنني أستطيع التنافس
مع الجميع، بالتأكيد أعطاني المزيد من
الثقة على الرغم من أن
الثقوب التسعة الأولى في الجولة الأخيرة لم ألعب جيدًا حتى
كان علي أن ألعبها  أنقذ نفسي طوال الوقت ولكن آه، نعم،
في النهاية، أصبح كل شيء
رائعًا جدًا، لذلك أنا سعيد حقًا بتزايد
ثقتها بنفسها، ومن السهل أن ننسى
أن بابنيك تبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا فقط، فهل
ستلعب أكثر في الولايات المتحدة هذا العام
؟  لعبت فقط في البطولات الكبرى في الولايات المتحدة،
لذا فقد كنت هناك ثلاث مرات، وكانت
تجربة رائعة ولكن في العام المقبل
سأبقى في أوروبا لأنني بحاجة إلى
إنهاء دراستي الثانوية، لذلك يكون الأمر أسهل إذا
كنت في أوروبا عما لو كنت سأفعل ذلك.  كن أمريكيًا، لذا فإن
الخطة هي LPGA 2024،
نعم ربما سنرى
أنك أحد أطول الضاربين في
الجولة، لذا أود أن أراك تسدد بعض
الضربات من أجلي، لذا احصل على ناديك المفضل
ودعنا نذهب
[موسيقى] واو،
هذا هو الحال  حسنًا، هل
هناك شيء تعمل عليه في
لعبتك الطويلة في الوقت الحالي،
نعم خاصة مع السائق الذي
يحاول باستمرار أن يطول لفترة أطول، فأنا أعمل على
جلسات الصالة الرياضية الخاصة بي وأحاول الحصول على المزيد من القوة
وبعض تمارين السرعة التي أقوم بها
بأسرع ما يمكن.  يمكننا أن نضرب واحدًا آخر، لقد
تمكنا من رؤية هذا
واو
[موسيقى]